[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this one take this is a special yard
Amanda
I just know what you know we really like
see ya I'm Jory oh no parental he talks
about you day and night
I think he loves you but don't say
anything
it won't say anything
[Music]
I loved dancing with you okay oh my god
these girls are so fun no they're not
yeah no yo he just made out with that
girl you are jealous what let's get out
of here seriously Amanda he's a cheater
you are drunk
I'm drinking water yeah Mexican water
tequila okay that's what that means
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you have manis no mayo dianna pepper
a candle raspberry vinaigrette hot sauce
yeah your number we gotta win hey wait
keep it the same price yeah that's your
purse
nothing gets wet let's go your first
kind of goes with everything do you make
are gonna get yesterday know what credit
card then when I fight in your purse it
muggers you didn't put a great guy to
buffers where'd you get all that new
stuff someone gave it to me did you get
a job yeah yeah I got a new job he would
hire you what do you mean you dropped
out of middle school I told you not to
tell anybody
I didn't hey that's my credit card
[Music]